hors du commun
aujourd'hui je vous emmène à
Saint-Étienne pour partager l'ordinaire
d'un commissariat de police
650 hommes et femmes au service de 220
000 habitants
braquage bagarre je vais vivre au rythme
de la police nationale
[Musique]
bonjour
je savais pas si il y a des modèles de
police de Saint-Etienne centre des
appels de police secours le fameux 17
vous allez vous rendre rue Victor Hugo à
Saint-Jean-Bonnefonds rue Victor Hugo à
Saint-Jean-Bonnefonds pour un accident
corporel de la route
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 les
fonctionnaires réceptionne les appels et
envoie les équipes
accident de la circulation différents
familiales ou bagarres sur la voie
publique ici on traite plus de 400
appels par jour des histoires de
quotidien dans un contexte social
souvent difficile parfois un simple coup
de fil lance les policiers sur une
grosse affaire
on est parti pour VMA en course de la
République un VMA un vol à main armé
des individus ont attaqué une bijouterie
ils sont en fuite
les informations parviennent par la
radio qu'est-ce qu'on a comme élément de
fuite ou de signalement
[Musique]
plusieurs unités sont mobilisées à la
poursuite des voleurs quand soudain
nous allons sur les lieux de
l'arrestation
pour répartir les équipages dans un
premier temps on va vous en envoyer un
équipage police secours sur le scooter à
la manœuvre le commissaire Fabrice
Cottel 42 ans chef de la sûreté
il est accompagné du grand patron
Jean-Christophe Bertrand il faut dire
que c'est un gros coup pour la sûreté
départementale
l'arrestation est intervenue au terme
d'un rodéo qui a mobilisé une quinzaine
de policiers
comment vous les avez intervien
ici
on vous les connaissez ouais
c'est des clients
les individus arrêtés sont suspectés du
braquage de la bijouterie ils se sont
enfuis en scooter et ont été pris en
chasse par les motards de la police
jusqu'à cette voie ferrée
je me trompe ou vous êtes content là ah
non là on est content
des fonctionnaires sur le terrain à
partir d'un signalement en plus un deux
roues c'est pas facile à pister en ville
là on est très content
le commissaire Cottel lance l'enquête
dernière instruction sur les lieux du
scooter on fait un ratissage des lieux
on prend des photos on récupère le
casque avec mesure conservatoire et
ensuite on fait remorquer le scooter à
la fourrière locale c'est bien reçu
il faut récolter un maximum de preuves
contre les suspects vous cherchez
l'arbre recherche
en attendant de trouver l'arme les
policiers ont fait une belle prise
et là on a
été volés
maintenant direction la bijouterie ou
d'autres policiers sont déjà au travail
[Musique]
faites les vitrines
les bijoux et donc les gars prennent la
fuite en scooter il y en a un qui a pas
eu le temps de s'enfuir
tout le monde en garde à vue etc
on sent qu'ils étaient speed quand même
parce que ils ont laissé des il y a des
bagues à plus de 1000 euros elles sont
restées ils en ont pris une partie
mais manifestement ils ont laissé plein
de trucs de valeur
à l'intérieur les traces du braquage
sont encore visibles et l'attaque a été
violente car le bijoutier a tenté de
résister blessé il a été évacué mais sa
femme est là
là
en moins d'une heure les voleurs ont été
arrêtés et le butin retrouvé c'est un
succès reste à savoir ce que donneront
les auditions
c'est une petite odeur de vestiaire de
vestiaire de foot de sport
retour au commissariat dans les
coulisses les vestiaires ou les
policiers s'équipent chaque jour avant
de partir en patrouille
en fait ça dépend un peu des collègues
mais on est censé la garder durant notre
cycle
[Musique]
voilà dans une dans une mallette des
chargée une malette à code la maladie
actuellement Geoffrey 24 ans c'est le
plus jeune gardien de la paix du
commissariat donc il y a quoi comme
équipement de base donc équipement de
base
avec un chargeur en plus
après la plupart des collègues ils ont
des gants bien sûr les notes classiques
et puis après pour ceux qui ont
l'habilitation passer des habitations
spéciales qu'on appelle le bâton de
police à poignet latérale sinon on
l'appelle le temps fort
[Musique]
un petit stage avec un petit test à la
fin pour pour voir si on est capable de
s'en servir
allez
avant de partir le chef de section donne
ses consignes et les objectifs de la
journée
je vous donnerai d'intensifier les vos
présences sur les zones commerciales
même si on sort du cadre strict de
l'anti bémol VMA vol à main armées c'est
le souci du moment commissariat on est à
quelques jours de Noël et le risque de
hold-up et maximum le braquage de la
bijouterie de ce matin en est la preuve
Geoffrey et son collègue Laurent
prennent donc la direction d'un centre
commercial ils vont sécuriser les lieux
à l'heure où les caisses sont pleines
et ce sont équipés d'un pistolet
mitrailleur
on essaie d'être le plus dissuasif
possible voilà on montre qu'il y a de la
police
on essaie d'être visible des gens des
agents de sécurité de prendre contact un
petit peu avec tout le monde
secteur calme rien à signaler la
prévention fait partie des missions de
la police mais Geoffrey et Laurent
savent qu'auprès de la population ça
n'est pas très payant
les gens nous considèrent comme
extrêmement répressif peut indulgent en
fait voilà les gens ils nous voient que
parlent ce que nous on appelle le
timbramande donc la menthe simplement en
fait il voit que ça et j'ai une petite
phrase moi qui me trotte devant je me
dis en fait les gens ils pensent qu'on
est toujours là quand il faut pas mais
jamais là quand il faut
pendant ce temps-là à l'hôtel de police
l'enquête sur le braquage de la
bijouterie se poursuit les trois
individus interpellés sont placés en
garde à vue et interrogés à tour de rôle
dommage on ne pourra pas les filmer
entre temps le bijoutier est sorti de
l'hôpital 9 points de suture un
traumatisme crânien et une côte cassée
[Musique]
quand je me penche ou je fais certains
mouvements
le commerçant aide les policiers dans
l'inventaire du butin il n'y en a tout
de même pour 130 000 euros et lui est au
fond du trou
de reprendre trop de risques dans le
métier et pourtant un métier qui est un
beau métier mais voilà
trois étages plus bas on fait un peu la
tête car les policiers du commissariat
viennent d'être dessaisies de l'enquête
sur le braquage de la bijouterie le
procureur a décidé de confier cette
enquête à la police judiciaire de
Saint-Étienne deux policiers de l'APG
sont déjà avec les braqueurs
je crois pour une audition d'accord
réfléchissez un petit peu ce que vous
avez fait et
je suis pas me répondre
c'est un dos droit d'accord on va pas
vous en priver c'est bien
la suite de l'enquête et chape donc aux
équipes de Fabrice Cottel et il faut
avaler la couleur
on est des saisies comme on dit mais
voilà il y a pas de malaise encore une
fois c'est chacun son rôle comment on
dit on a les boules quand ça arrive
dites pas le contraire
si l'APJ reprend l'enquête c'est parce
qu'à la suite des premières auditions
l'affaire se révèle un peu plus complexe
le plus jeune des suspects
âgé de 16 ans aurait pu servir d'appâts
les deux autres majeurs
je trouve que sur la fin de la faire en
fait on a un élément qu'on n'avait pas
tout à fait au départ c'est le rôle d'un
des interpellés on a des doutes sur son
activité pendant cette opération
qu'est-ce qu'il dit lui en gros ce qui
nous fait pour lui pour lui il est
plutôt victime c'est-à-dire que il
serait plutôt victime plutôt victime
d'une séquestration il aurait été emmené
par deux personnes pour rentrer enfin
voilà alors que pour rentrer dans la
bijouterie dans la bijouterie exactement
les policiers de l'APJ expliquent aux
mineurs ce qui va se passer il clame son
innocence mais il est loin d'être sorti
d'affaires je le connais même pas
monsieur c'est pas maintenant là pour
l'instant je suis en train de te dire
Lisa pour l'instant tu es là pour ça
d'accord tu étais peut-être au moins
mais pour l'instant c'est comme ça
j'ai vu ta mère tout à l'heure je l'ai
rassuré
tout à l'heure c'est bon je vais lui
parler et vous l'avez dit que j'étais
prêt ah je lui dis qu'on allait le voir
s'inquiète un petit peu c'est normal tu
es là
elle m'a dit aussi que tu as une
mauvaise fréquentation ouais mais je
suis pour rien moi elle est pas surprise
le jeune homme sera finalement blanchi
et relâché il a convaincu l'APG que
c'est sous la menace qu'il a participé
au braquage quant aux deux principaux
suspects des récidivistes ils ont été
présentés au parquet plus écroué
le lendemain matin dans la cour du
commissariat
et bonjour
très heureux de vous rencontrer
bonjour bonjour
Jeannine buisson 49 ans commissaire
divisionnaire
elle commence toujours sa journée par
une tournée des services première étape
les interpellations de la nuit
[Musique]
de jus
en fait vous avez
bonne journée
la commissaire Buisson est à la tête du
service de sécurité de proximité
c'est la police du quotidien celle qui
est au plus près de la population
comme chaque semaine elle réunissent les
équipes police secours et les unités
spécialisées comme la brigade
anti-criminalité ou la brigade canine
bien
fin de semaine prochaine on débute
l'opération tranquillité vacances
opération tiold-up et continue bien sûr
voilà donc dans votre antre
le job de Janine buisson c'est de gérer
au quotidien 320 policiers en tenue sur
une zone qui compte 220 000 habitants
mais là vous êtes des RH quoi de la
police de Saint-Étienne
[Musique]
de personnes d'une c'est vrai que ça
soit peu correspondre à une fonction de
DRH mais après l'opérationnel après il y
a du relationnel avec avec les élus avec
les différents partenaires c'est une
petite entreprise dans le dans ce
domaine là dans le domaine de la
sécurité on est vraiment au cœur de la
cité
[Musique]
tous les policiers suivent des
entraînements obligatoires et
aujourd'hui ça se passe ici au centre de
formation
[Musique]
changement de tenue pour la commissaire
Busson et pour moi-même d'ailleurs gilet
pare-balles de rigueur direction le
stand de tir
les dernières munitions sont très
difficiles à mettre carrément en bas
tous les fonctionnaires doivent
effectuer trois sessions de tirs par an
allez si vous êtes prêt vous sortez
votre âme et vous tirez deux cartes
allez
ok tranquillement
[Musique]
les exercices s'enchaînent du simple tir
jusqu'à la simulation d'une situation de
terrain Périgueux
il y en a un qui va voir
pour pas la mettre en danger on ferme
les angles pour pas la mettre en danger
allez
est-ce qu'il bouge
la puissance
l'ambiance est détendue mais il ne faut
pas s'y tromper ils savent qu'ils
doivent toujours se tenir prêt à se
servir de leur arme
vous faites quel bilan
est important de se familiariser avec
l'arme très régulièrement tout au long
de l'année il faut tirer régulièrement
pour avoir l'arme bien en main avoir une
bonne prise au niveau de de larmes vous
avez tiré déjà en réel en intervention
en intervention je n'ai jamais eu je
n'ai jamais eu moi j'ai jamais eu
l'occasion en intervention
c'est s'entraider pour ne jamais le
faire en fait ça va pas le but mais
c'est s'entraîner pour éventuellement le
faire un jour
bien merci
alors après les pros les amateurs on me
propose de m'exercer au tir flash-ball
lanceur de 40 fusil à pompe ou pistolet
mitrailleur j'ai le choix qu'est-ce
qu'on voulait essayer qu'est-ce que je
veux essayer je vous montre d'abord et
vous faites après ça vous voit comme ça
fusil à pompe calibre 12 c'est une arme
extrêmement dangereuse et destructrice
le risque d'être se faire découper ici
je vais verrouiller attention
ok immédiatement j'ai Jacques et je
remets une à l'intérieur d'accord
non je vais vous aider et vous verrez
que mettez pas le doigt sur la détente
parce que la cartouche est chambrée
ok descendez bien la pointe de coude
voilà avancer un petit peu c'est quand
vous voulez
ok même chose allez marche arrière
marche avant OK
marche arrière marche avant
enlever le doigt et faites attention
parce que votre visage il s'approche de
plus en plus au fur et à mesure vous
tirer
il y a plus rien ok regardez ça
et hormis celle-là 1 2 3 j'en ai trois
dans le mille alors ça c'est la mienne
la première ça c'est à vous et ça c'est
à vous d'accord
3 balles dans la cible c'est pas mal
pour un débutant mais fini de jouer aux
policiers et aux voleurs
fin de journée à l'écart du centre-ville
sur les hauteurs de Saint-Étienne
ça commence à sentir le renard je pense
que c'est là
Kaiser Atos enjoy voyou ne sont pas
vraiment des chiens à sa mère
attention sa mort
bienvenue à la brigade canine
de recherche stupe
c'est le malinoise
mais avec un très très beau caractère
très gros caractère mais qui travaille
bien donc après il faut
gérer voilà d'autres chiens sont dédiés
au patrouilles le major héricanon nous
présente ses animaux qui sont dressés
pour être agressifs enfin si on arrive à
s'entendre
j'aurais envie de
les caresser et
tout avec eux mais bon on m'a expliqué
que c'était pas possible
la brigade va partir en patrouille mais
avant le départ il y a une étape obligée
10 15 minutes avant de passer au
véhicule pour s'assurer qu'ils aient
bien fait leurs besoins
comme ça ils sont opérationnels
ça commence par ça
commence par ça non
4 chiens et 4 policiers sont mobilisés
chaque nuit la canine a un champ
d'action très large de la mission la
plus anodine à la plus tragique parfois
la nuit ne fait que commencer
[Musique]
il est 19h premier appel du Central donc
apparemment s'il y a des perturbateurs
qui empêcheraient des gens de rentrer de
sortir d'un garage
direction le quartier de montréno
secteur sensible à la périphérie de la
ville
on verra sur place la physionomie des
lieux commence à ça va se dérouler si il
est opportun de sortir les chiens ou non
ça on verra uniquement sur place
les policiers disposent de très peu
d'informations mais ils savent que la
situation sur place peut rapidement
dégénérer
une fois arrivé David décide de sortir
les chiens
s'aventurer seul dans le garage et trop
risqué
et dès l'entrée un bruit suspect
précipite l'action
c'est fermé
en courant quand on est accroché
on va prendre un peu mieux dépasser
il y a rien du tout
après 10 minutes les policiers stoppent
leurs recherches les perturbateurs leur
ont échappé ils sont déçus mais pas
autant que leur chien vu son but c'est
de retrouver quelqu'un et puis de
pouvoir faire son travail de faire une
frappe musée éventuellement d'aller le
mordre lui c'est ce qu'il cherche le
chien voilà pour lui c'est infructueux
donc il est frustré donc il faut quand
même le féliciter pour lui faire
comprendre qu'il a bien travaillé et que
la prochaine fois ce sera peut-être
payant pour lui cette fois-ci les chiens
n'ont pas attaqué mais plus tard j'aurai
l'occasion de voir de quoi ils sont
capables
[Musique]
le calme est revenu les hommes de la
brigade canine sillonnent la ville quand
tombe un nouvel appel
[Musique]
qui a trouvé un pendu apparemment juste
derrière
il n'en croit pas leurs oreilles des
témoins auraient aperçu un homme pendu
au beau milieu d'une zone HLM
on va venir avec vous on va se garer
[Musique]
détache le désespéré tu tiens
et tout d'un coup
Franck vient de percevoir un léger
souffle
[Musique]
pour information de la décrocher
c'est pas je pense pas qu'ils sont
encore décédés en on a un petit semblant
de souffre encore donc si vous pouvez
dépêcher le SAMU sur place là j'ai
encore le cœur
[Musique]
j'ai plus le pot
le SAMU arrive 10 minutes plus tard les
médecins vont tenter l'impossible sous
le regard des deux policiers
il y a quelques années quand je
travaille en police secours
effectivement on trouve pas fréquemment
mais assez souvent mais
les gens suicidés ou en tentative de
suicide depuis que je suis en Brillat de
cynophile un peu moins je dois avouer
aujourd'hui
c'est assez surprenant je pose toujours
la question en fait ce qui les a poussé
à faire ça
pourquoi
après cette personne qu'elle a la
réponse malheureusement
une demi-heure s'est écoulé une
demi-heure de massage cardiaque acharné
ouais donc c'est Delta Charlie Delta
confirmé
Delta Charlie Delta pour décéder les
médecins n'ont pas pu le sauver dur dur
pour Stéphane et Franck
déçu que le SAMU n'est populaire réanimé
ou un gros sentiment d'impuissance
je pense qu'il faut prendre beaucoup de
recul et
essayer
de se projeter dans des images positives
et voilà bon on laisse ça au boulot on
fait 8h30 8h10 de vacation et puis après
faut laisser ça sur sur le site quoi
faut pas ramener ça à la maison
mais déjà il faut repartir la brigade
canine n'étant patrouille toute la nuit
[Musique]
le lendemain matin changement d'ambiance
j'ai rendez-vous dans un petit coin de
campagne et je retrouve la commissaire
buisson en tenue de jogging alors c'est
quoi ce jogging commissaire un policier
ça a le droit de devenir un peu
bedonnant ou pas
je dis pas que après
certains peuvent
lâcher un peu ou évoluer différemment
mais d'une manière générale d'une
manière générale chacun essaie de garder
la forme c'est important je vous laisse
je cours
[Rires]
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
la commissaire Busson et ça gardera
proche toutes les semaines 11 km tout de
même il mérite quelques encouragements
au bout d'une vingtaine de minutes
l'écart se creusent entre la commissaire
et ses hommes je le sais puisque je suis
la course en voiture
les [__] vous attendent fort
en un peu plus d'une heure la boucle est
bouclée et retour à la case départ
vont forcément l'admiration
[Rires]
le père vite et quand le chef de service
donne l'impulsion ça c'est important
donner l'impulsion oui et puis après
derrière il faut suivre enfin où
la commissaire Buisson a bien raison de
se maintenir en forme car ce soir il va
y avoir du sport
ça va se passer au coeur de la ville ici
dans ce qu'on appelle le chaudron le
célèbre stade de foot Geoffroy-Guichard
Saint-Étienne reçoit Lyon c'est le derby
merci vous êtes parmi nous la rivalité
entre les deux clubs est historiques la
rencontre de ce soir est à haut risque
alors à 5h du match c'est le début des
grandes manœuvres
alors petit élément de contexte qu'on
retrouve pas forcément tous les ans
c'est que cette année les deux clubs
jouent dans les premières places du
classement puisque avant les bâti hier
soir l'OL était premier et Saint-Étienne
3e donc à la rivalité traditionnelle un
peu exacerbée entre deux villes
s'ajoutent aussi un enjeu sportif fort
entre entre les deux clubs
autour du numéro 1 de la police
départementale les chefs d'unités
mobilisés ce soir Janine buisson à la
mission la plus délicate sécuriser
l'arrivée des cars de supporters
lyonnais
c'est là qu'il faut être vigilant parce
que plus l'écart sont exposés sur le
public plus on risque d'avoir des
individus qui s'en prennent au car qui
jettent des projectiles
pour gagner du temps est-ce qu'on peut
faire rentrer en double file parce qu'on
a deux accès ce qu'on va faire
les bus lyonnais entre rond dans le
stade sur deux fils pour limiter les
risques d'attaque
[Musique]
merci à tous
17h arrivé au stade le coup d'envoi n'a
lieu qu'à 21h mais le dispositif est
déjà déployé
donc l'escadron est là le commandant
d'escadron est en train de
donner ses instructions
rejoint l'arrière de l'enceinte c'est à
partir de là à l'écart des supporters
stéphanois que les Lyonnais accèderont
aux tribus là on est sur la zone
d'entrée des visiteurs vous voyez et
donc l'appellation les palpations se
feront derrière
les guichets
pour l'heure il s'agit de donner les
dernières instructions et de répartir au
mieux les effectifs
des visiteurs OK
ce soir il y aura plus de 600
fonctionnaires de police mobilisés 200
sur le seul secteur à la charge de la
commissaire la zone visiteur est une
zone sensible très sensible que l'on
confie sur tous les matchs à risque
c'est ma zone de travail
à l'intérieur du stade on comprend mieux
pourquoi la tension sera maximale entre
les supporters
alors ici nous avons la face à moi sur
sur l'angle la tribune réservée aux
supporters lyonnais c'est le bloc V30 et
puis vous avez ici sur ma gauche une
partie d'attributs où se trouveront des
supporters stefanois notamment les Magic
Fans c'est un club d'ultra et vous
constatez qu'il y a une séparation en
plexiglas
la séparation est transparente donc ils
vont se voir il va y avoir un visuel et
ils vont s'investir ils sont quand même
très proches
19h toutes les unités sont positionnées
l'instant critique c'est maintenant
les Lyonnais font leur entrée dans
Geoffroy-Guichard
900 supporters répartis dans 17 car la
situation semble sous contrôle pour le
moment
tout va bien
et ça pourrait être plus chaud oui oui
on se méfie toujours d'arriver une
opinée de supporters et justement
de faire un mouvement à la CRS pour les
bloquer
150 supporters de Saint-Etienne viennent
de surgir ils attaquent le convoi
lyonnais
OK
[Musique]
les forces de l'ordre ont été prises de
cours
elles doivent reprendre la situation en
main au plus vite
l'hélicoptère indique aux équipes au sol
où sont les assaillants
la progression est difficile toutes les
unités sont mobilisées y compris la
canine
et au bout de quelques minutes les
ultras stéphanois sont repoussés
on a un groupe de
[Musique]
Stéphane qui a attaqué
qui est arrivé j'étais caché on les a
pas vu arriver et il nous avait vu ils
ont attaqué les bus de supporters
lyonnais ça a été très violent
bilan de l'opération de blessés légers
parmi les forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
le ton est donné les supporters veulent
en découdre et la soirée promet d'être
longue
[Applaudissements]
à quelques minutes du coup d'envoi les
spectateurs sont minutieusement fouillés
[Applaudissements]
et en tribune l'ambiance est déjà
électrique
[Applaudissements]
ce sera comme ça de la première à la
dernière minute du match
en fait on a les Lyonnais qui sont entre
les Stéphanois c'est assez
impressionnant
pour le moment aucun incident majeur a
signalé mais au PC sécurité on retient
son souffle
on est à 5 minutes de la fin on va
devoir gérer les phases d'après match et
ces phases d'après match quoi c'est le
départ du bus des joueurs de l'OL et le
départ des supporters de Lyon évidemment
c'est un petit peu plus délicat puisque
Saint-Étienne est actuellement en train
de perdre le match à zéro donc ça peut
exciter certains supporters
la fin du match se déroulera sans accroc
malgré la défaite en zéro des Stéphanois
6 individus seront tout de même
interpellés pendant la soirée
5h30 le lendemain matin au commissariat
à l'étage de la brigade des stupéfiants
c'est l'effervescence
il a 15000 possibilités il peut sauter
dans la cour partir par les garages en
chantier qui communiquent avec les
autres bâtiments il peut prendre le
petit muret sauter sur les jardins d'un
côté ou alors carrément traverser ce
petit muret et sauter sur les garages et
des boulets par ici tu vois dans cette
rue
toute la brigade est sur le pied de
guerre et d'autres unités spécialisées
sont venues prêter main fortes car ce
matin c'est une très grosse opération
qui est lancée qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire là
on a une cinquantaine d'hommes qui sont
en bas on a une trentaine d'hommes du
GPN
de Lyon et un peu de GPN de Marseille on
est sur 6 objectifs pour un trafic de
stupéfiants plutôt d'origine albanaise
donc chacun son rôle les objectifs sont
bien déterminés le vôtre et quant à nous
bah écoutez on part sur l'objectif entre
guillemets le plus dangereux la tête de
réseau les individus sont ces types
d'être armée enfin très probablement
armée d'où les précautions prises
le GIPN le groupe d'intervention de la
police nationale une unité d'élite
sur entraînée
l'objectif du jour est de démanteler un
trafic d'héroïne 6 interpellations sont
programmées
aux côtés du commissaire Cottel la plus
risquée
l'arrestation du chef du réseau quelque
part dans le centre ville de
Saint-Étienne
silence de rigueur pour garantir le
succès de l'opération
il est 6h du matin l'heure légale pour
taper comme disent les policiers
en quelques secondes le JPM fait le tour
de l'appartement et neutralise au
premier étage leur objectif
de façon musclée
concrètement l'interpellation a eu lieu
sans problème l'individu a été
interpellé il s'est pas laissé faire il
s'est débattu on avait un calibre qui
était posé sur sa table de nuit
elle sera à voir si des factice ou pas
quoi qu'il en soit dans l'apparence
c'était quand même qui est libre au
moment d'interpellation et puis on va
dérouler tranquillement et là on va
commencer par la perquisition
pour l'homme interpellé c'est le début
d'un long processus judiciaire
qui pointeront aujourd'hui encore de 24
heures et encore 48 heures dans le cadre
d'un trafic de stupéfiant
[Rires]
la perquisition commence tout est
fouillé dans les moindres détails
et très vite les enquêteurs trouvent ces
billets cachés qui pourraient bien
provenir du trafic d'héroïne
d'argent comme vous l'avez vu des
billets qui sont bien rangés etc puis là
aussi matérialise un peu le trafic
puisqu'on sait qu'il serait en monnaie
dans cet état maintenant on attend les
choses Sud pour justement essayer de
trouver des produits c'est vraiment
notre objectif principal
mais avant même l'arrivée de la brigade
canine la perquisition est fructueuse
qu'est-ce que c'est ça
OK
200 g d'héroïne à peine caché au moment
où circa la chienne des stups entre en
action les policiers en sont convaincus
d'autres paquets de drogues sont cachés
dans l'appartement
le majorcanon observe attentivement le
comportement de l'animal
déjà le repère
a priori il est beaucoup plus intéressé
par ce par cet endroit
la cuisine ça sent l'héroïne et en effet
bilan de la perquisition 5000 euros
d'argent liquide et un kilo 2 d'héroïne
saisie à la revente il n'y en a pour
24000 euros l'homme interpellé va devoir
s'expliquer
[Musique]
ce genre d'opération reste exceptionnel
au quotidien le travail des policiers se
résume souvent à des patrouilles pour
rassurer nous retrouvons Geoffrey et
Laurent les deux gardiens de la paix de
police secours ils partent en
intervention
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors
parking d'Auchan
parking de champvillar donc centre
commercial donc apparemment on aurait
une personne blessée
je suppose que ça doit être les agents
de sécurité qui ont prévenu donc on va
aller voir sur place pourquoi vous le
savez apparemment ce serait pour une
place de stationnement
c'est le dernier week-end avant Noël les
centres commerciaux sont pris d'assaut
deux automobilistes se bagarrent pour la
même place de parking il faut faire vite
mais ça bouchonne et Geoffrey doit
adopter une conduite musclée
c'est pas trop moi la conduite comme ça
un peu
l'estomac quoi et puis on est un peu
tendu on s'accroche un peu comme ça quoi
à notre arrivée les pompiers sont déjà
sur place ils soignent l'un des deux
automobilistes qui a reçu un coup de
poing les policiers interrogent
l'agresseur
c'est quoi une droite
pour une place de parking voilà
maintenant c'est fait vous avez il avait
pas cher ça mais vous aviez pas non plus
après avoir rappelé quelques règles de
bon sens les policiers relèvent les
identités l'agresseur sera convoquée si
la victime porte plainte
ils en viennent aux mains pour des
broutilles en fait plus
que bon ça c'est
que pour un truc vous savez quoi ce
genre de conneries ça pourrait m'arriver
moi
[Rires]
de retour au commissariat Geoffrey et
Laurent doivent s'atteler à la paperasse
aujourd'hui leur patrouille a été plutôt
tranquille ce qui n'est pas toujours le
cas pour les hommes de police secours
quotidiennement confrontés à la réalité
de la rue
on va publier qu'au bout d'un moment
c'est au présent ce qu'on n'est pas on
n'est pas spécialisé en fait on voit de
tout faut essayer de d'encaisser mais
surtout de relâcher un petit peu quand
on a en privé et de pas y penser parce
que si on en question on peut pas
avoir toute la misère du monde sur sur
soi et après il y a des gens qui
craquent et qui supportent plus quoi
donc faut savoir relâcher la pression en
fait
au premier étage la brigade des
stupéfiants poursuit son enquête les
policiers mettent la drogue saisie sous
scellée
c'est pour savoir le degré de dosage
d'héroïne pour savoir si elle a été
coupée d'où elle provient également
9 personnes ont été interpellées dans le
cadre du trafic d'héroïne
l'homme suspecté d'être le chef du
réseau dont nous avons suivi
l'arrestation ce matin va être interrogé
pour la première fois
la porte se referme
la garde à vue pourra durer 96 heures
dès les maximum dans les enquêtes de
stup
4 jours plus tard l'homme est transféré
au palais de justice il est déféré
devant la juge d'instruction en charge
du dossier
à l'issue de son interrogatoire de
première comparution il est écroué
[Musique]
nouvelle journée nouveau décor Geoffrey
le jeune gardien de la paix matin avec
ses collègues de police secours
ça va bonjour vous allez bien vous avez
carrément les maillots
Barcelone et là Saint-Étienne
[Rires]
est au complet dit policiers au repos et
donc en civil enfin pour être exact en
maillot de foot les Verts l'OM Barcelone
ou la sélestao pas de doute à
Saint-Étienne le ballon rond est
incontournable petite précision cet
après-midi on ne joue pas sur un terrain
mais sur des consoles de jeux avant le
début de la compétition je procède au
tirage au sort
le seul innocent qui est ici c'est moi
c'est parti
PSG
face de poule match aller match retour
et enfin phase finale pas moins de 30
rencontres sur trois écrans geoffrey est
gonflé à bloc et dès les premières
minutes il marque
oh non mais non
mais voilà mais non
les matchs s'enchaînent le tournoi est
lancé depuis deux heures déjà et ça va
dur
[Musique]
à peu près en gros le temps que tous les
matchs se fassent que on fait même les
matchs de perdant donc je pense que tout
le monde
vu que ça aura fait déjà la journée
après les femmes elles gueules donc du
coup on rentre à la maison parce que
sinon en fait on est la police mon école
ça en fait
pas de doute le groupe est soudé et
l'amitié entre eux est très forte même
en dehors du service la finale est
encore loin un rendez-vous matin
[Musique]
fin de journée à Saint-Étienne
à la nuit tombée quelque part dans un
parking du centre-ville je retrouve la
brigade canine
ce soir l'équipe du major Cancalon est
accompagné de l'homme d'attaque un homme
entraîné à se faire attaquer
[Musique]
ça s'appelle une frappe muselée le chien
ne mord pas mais neutralise l'individu
en le faisant tomber
ça t'a fait ça
peut être dangereux mais bon on apprend
amortir donc ça va anticipe bien mais ça
sent les fait c'est ce qu'on cherche
ce que recherche Stefano l'entraîneur
des chiens c'est la radicalité des
attaques avec la muselière d'abord
puissant mais mieux vaut alors enfiler
le costume adéquat
oui c'est bien
le principe la major alors on le
principe c'est une attaque au bourdon
donc nous on travaille beaucoup sur le
l'agressivité du géant c'est très
important il était dressé uniquement
pour l'agressivité pour l'agressivité
avec une base obéissance bien entendu
mais on travaille beaucoup cet
agressivité je dois être un peu fou je
viens d'accepter la proposition du major
Cancalon de me faire attaquer à mon tour
allez la chercher
simplement ce mouvement là suffir
on sent bien la pince à l'intérieur
[Musique]
fin de journée à faire de stups bagarre
audition et en cas de bonus une attaque
de malinois je suis gâté
[Musique]
dernière journée à l'hôtel de police de
Saint-Étienne
je débarque dans les couloirs au moment
où deux jeunes femmes sont conduites
pour être interrogées elles sont
soupçonnées d'avoir extorquer de
l'argent à une troisième personne dites
vulnérable
on va faire une confrontation ma
collègue va vous poser des questions
vous aurez chacun la parole d'accord
simplement vous ne parlez pas tous en
même temps vous ne criez pas ça sert à
rien parce que si la confrontation se
passe mal on arrête tout et on entend le
parquet
c'est une confrontation les deux jeunes
femmes font face à la victime
euh cette jeune femme en sweat blanc à
côté d'elle son petit ami
est-ce qu'elle a la maison elle vous a
menacé chez vous
urgent elle allait pas sortir chez moi
voilà
[Musique]
on va stopper la confrontation
devant les policiers le petit ami de la
plaignante menace une des interpellés et
ça ne serait pas la première fois
[Musique]
c'est bon c'est bon et on va mettre fin
à la confrontation
c'est le parquet qui décidera des suites
de la faire les policiers eux ont fait
leur job jusqu'au bout en tentant de
démêler les fils de cet imbroglio sur
fond de misère sociale
est-ce que vous voyez la vie
différemment
les autres gens de vos amis parce que
vous faites ce métier là et vous êtes
confronté toute la journée à ce type de
situation
moi je pense que nous on fait partie
d'une profession on est à celui-ci de la
société lucide
on sait très bien ce qui se passe depuis
longtemps et je pense qu'on est tous
lucide de ce qui se passe après faut
toujours prendre du recul on a aussi
chacun une vie privée heureusement qu'on
fait la part des choses
heureusement
c'est la fin de mon séjour au
commissariat de Saint-Étienne je
retrouve le premier flic du département
Jean-Christophe Bertrand le patron de
cette police du quotidien cette police
souvent déconsidérée et pourtant
indispensable
seules les belles affaires intéressent
les médias seuls celle-ci sont valorisés
donc notre travail il est méconnu mais
nos concitoyens quand même ne s'y
trompent pas ils savent bien qu'au
quotidien c'est nous qui sommes à leur
côté c'est pas les c'est pas la police
judiciaire elle est pas là à patrouiller
elle est pas là intervenir au domicile
quand tu es une femme battue elle est
pas là elle est à une sortie d'école
parce que il y a du raquette c'est quand
même ce travail là qui importe à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
en France ils sont un peu plus de 70 000
fonctionnaires de police à assurer ce
travail de sécurité publique
il est temps pour moi de repartir à la
découverte de nouveaux horizons où ma
tante d'autres hommes et femmes au
métier exceptionnels
[Musique]